- So, everybody is sad
that "This Is Us" is coming to an end.
So, are you feeling kind
of bittersweet about it?
Like, it's a great cast,
but are you excited
about doing new things?
- I mean, look, I'll be honest.
For me, I don't really
work with anybody but Mandy
'cause I'm deceased in the present day.
- Oh, that's true, that's true!
- So, I never work with the kids.
- But you see everyone, right?
- No, no.
- Oh my gosh, that's weird.
- I see them when we do press.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- So the thing is like, they'll be on set.
Wherever we are, they'll
just kind of group together
and inside joke, inside joke.
And I'm lost dead dad, I
have no idea what's going on.
- I'm lost dead dad. (laughs)
- For me, it's like, yes,
it is a little bittersweet
to leave the group.
But for me, it's the crew.
It's always the crew.
I mean, you spend day
after day with, you know,
the people that you're with all the time.
You see 'em, you walk past 'em,
you know their kid's names,
you know everything about 'em.
And then it's just gone and done.
- Yeah.
- And you move on.
- It is true though.
I still see the crew
from like, 20 years ago
when I won "American Idol."
I still know the crew
and I run into them at awards
shows and stuff. It's so crazy
'cause we've all grown
up together for 20 years.
And those are the people that you see,
and you'll still see on
different productions.
- Yep, absolutely.
Yeah.
- Yeah, that is true.